[Music]
actor activist and author alyssa milano
first appeared on her screen back in
1984 she was just 11. you remember she's
best known for her roles on that hit tv
show who's the boss and charm look at
her and now for her activism in the me
too movement and on issues like voting
rights now she's starring in a new
netflix film it's called brazen it's
about a crime novelist who gets
permission to join the police
investigation into her sister's murder
now in this clip she and the lead
detective have one of their many
disagreements about the case
i like her captain she's decisive
fresh thinking can make all the
difference huh look ed i respect what
you do your expertise how about you do
the same for me results driven here at
grace in the real world that's how it
works okay you know what you want me to
believe that jonathan breeswood is not a
suspect
i'll keep an open mind
sorry um that's grace miller in action
alyssa joins us now for her first
interview about this movie hello alyssa
milano good to see you
hello good to see you too as always
kisses i wish i could hug you
no i wish you were here too but we all
understand the covet rules but this is
the thing you play a character who's a
champion for women who doesn't want
women to be exploited and who bucks the
status quo must have been a very
difficult role for you to play
yeah i fell right into it
talk about it talk about you know art
imitating life
that's what i thought when i was
watching it but the other cool thing
about the movie alyssa is that you were
also the executive producer in addition
to one of the star the starring role in
the movie what was the difference for
you to be an ep on the project and also
star in the star in this movie
what was the difference for you i think
that there's i think i think that
there's a
a bigger emotional investment
when you're also part of the other side
of the camera
um
you know you really you want it to be
great
and we had such an incredible cast and
crew
uh monica mitchell who's our director
who's this incredible incredible
director and so you know it was it was
exciting and i gotta tell you i'm a
little nervous
because it drops on on thursday and
well i mean you know it to
to
to lead a a cast and crew on a netflix
movie and then have so much at stake
once it it drops you know i just don't
want to disappoint anyone um especially
netflix who is so gracious to give me
the opportunity
alyssa you're going to be fine this is
based on a nora roberts novel everyone
likes a good mystery and this is a good
mystery uh
with a lot of twists a lot of twists and
turns and who done it uh did you read
the book first were you into nora
roberts before this script came to you
i did read the book first and i had a
conversation with nora roberts that i i
said to her you know what tell me
something about grace that isn't in the
book
that you want me to include because i
was looking for
you know just character quirks or
interesting things about her
and she said to me that grace is the
type of girl that'll sit on the counter
and drink a beer and have a slice of
pizza and i was like that's all i need
and i mean she's such an incredible
writer and
i can do that i can do that yeah she's
such an incredible writer especially for
for character you know female lead
characters so i was uh it was really
just a blessing
you know we also shot during the
pandemic which had
many many many challenges as you can
imagine
um and it was it was kind of the first
time i
during the pandemic where i opened the
door and i had to
you know
be in the presence of people who weren't
in my pod or my family and it was yeah
it was scary but the first time through
all the masks
yeah through all the masks and the ppe i
think that we made
a really lovely
film um and i think that parts of the
pandemic
are reflected in
uh in the film you'll you'll see that
there is a certain um
closeness and connection that that we
made and also like a freshness because
we weren't able to rehearse at all right
yeah right you know so
so to be able to
go ahead
no i just want to get back to something
you said you mentioned the crew and many
of the people that made this film
possible were women including the
director as you mentioned do you believe
that there has been improvement when it
comes to um women having roles behind
the camera when it comes to the film
industry
i do and i love this question thank you
so much we
had a 50
um
female crew which was incredible
uh but also you know i think we have
come a long way but i think we still
have a long a long way to go
and um you know we'll just keep keep
making stories from from a woman's
perspective
um keep telling diverse stories uh and i
think that we'll get i think that we'll
get there i i hope that you can feel
that the industry is changing and that
perspective
is changing and shifting in the way we
tell these stories
yeah you have a bit of a go-to with
covid um listen you were very public
about what it how it affected you
because you did have a tough time i just
want to know how you're doing today
thank you thank you i am
much better
good
yes for sure i am much better i uh after
my second moderna vaccine my long haul
symptoms started to ease up which i
guess happens to like 40
of of long-haul patients
but i still have shortness of breath
sometimes and heart palpitations and
tingling in my hands
um
and it'll come out of nowhere uh
you know and it's
it's scary when it happens
alyssa please know this we're all glad
you're okay and that we are cheering you
on with brazen thank you so much for
getting up early out there thanks a lot
raising begins through having me
thank you brazen begins streaming on
netflix tomorrow and we will be right
back
[Music]